three two one go bubble and three - guys
we're going and to the couch do it a
little bit and three two one take good
morning everybody welcome back to the
summit 3-bike gigabyte this is the only
top tier professional gaming event where
the teams have left to themselves to
compete and play for over $250,000 we've
got a unique twist instead of being at a
live venue we're holding this event from
our house five of us live here whole
year round we completely renovated the
house we moved all about furniture out
this is my bedroom that we're in
actually I feel right at home we have
the six best teams in the world we have
the three best teams from China they're
taking on the three best Western teams
evil geniuses from America cloud nine as
well as team secret from Europe so it's
this interesting beast versus West
showdown are they just playing in
everyday suburban home for us it's not
really just the game people are like all
yours playing games that must be so cool
and so far then it is but we put
everything that we have into it and we
practice for you know months
all right everyone welcome it's the
Samba 3 presented by gigabyte any
popular traditional sport score more
points you win
that is not how that operates dota 2
it's virtual chess in a lot of ways
without the rules there's five people on
each side you're running at each other
everyone's kind of like a wizard cuz you
got abilities and you're killing each
other it's really one of the first [ __ ]
truly global games there's at least
twenty countries represented at this
land we all come from similar
backgrounds no matter where we're from
we all went through the same struggles
with our parents trying to convincing
them that this is what we want to do and
this is who we are
I've been gaming my whole life you know
so ever since like Sega and n64 I am
from the Midwest Mayan game name is PPD
and I play for Team Evil Geniuses team
secret is probably pretty big rivals of
our just because they have our TZ insigh
who left our team because they didn't
think we were good enough to win
I just kind of left because it was like
reaching the point where we can't really
change it you leave one theme for
another the team you previously left
this is gonna be the most fun to play
against because you know you really want
to prove that you better than them for
these players these teams it's
everything is the only thing they do
right now and they're making a lot of
money year-round because of the prices
of these events you're not the best
you're not making a living off of it